now although case numbers remain high
and i'll cover the implications of that
shortly
they are very much right now on a
downward path
to illustrate that point uh in the seven
days up to
second of july there were an average of
3
305 new cases being reported
each day but in the seven days
to the 16th of july that had fallen to
an average of
2112 new cases a day so that amounts to
a decline
in the past two weeks of more than one
third and
that is very encouraging because of that
we were able to go ahead
yesterday with the move to level zero
but as i said a moment ago case numbers
though they
are definitely falling do remain higher
than we should be comfortable with
covet as we know is highly infectious
indeed delta is significantly more
transmissible
than previous variants of the virus and
although vaccination is weakening the
link between
covert cases and serious illness the
virus is still potentially dangerous and
of course
long covert is affecting many including
those
in younger age groups all of this means
that
vigilance and care remain really
important
restrictions were eased yesterday as
part of a gradual process
but restrictions were not abandoned
yesterday
important measures and mitigations do
remain in place and we continue to ask
people
across the country and i do so again
today to treat the threat
that covert poses seriously at this
stage
now obviously we want to extend the
protection of the vaccine as far as
we can and to that end the advice
yesterday from the joint committee and
vaccination and immunization the jcvi
on vaccination of 12 to 17 year olds
is important and i want to spend just a
couple of minutes talking about that
at this stage given that it considers
the risk
of 12 to 17 year olds falling seriously
ill from covert to be very
low the jcvi is not recommending that we
vaccinate
all young people in that 12 to 17 year
old age group
now the scottish government has always
followed the advice of the jcvi and for
good reason you'll have heard me talk
about that before
in different contexts including recently
that eight week
interval between first and second doses
but i am acutely aware that some other
countries
are vaccinating younger teenagers and i
certainly consider
it to be extremely important that this
is not
ruled out here so to that end the chief
medical officer is writing to the jcvi
asking that the benefit of vaccinating
all 12 to 17
year olds is kept under close and
ongoing review
and that it takes account of all
available data from countries
already doing this and i think that is
really
important if there is a benefit to be
got from vaccinating younger
teenagers then it's really important
that we make sure younger people don't
lose out
on that in the meantime though and most
immediately
we intend to get on with implementing
what the jcvi
is recommending and it is recommending
that vaccines should be offered
to specific groups of 12 to 17 year olds
vaccination is already available to 16
and 17 year olds
at higher risk of falling seriously ill
and they will continue to be eligible
but in addition the jcvi is advising
that 12
to 15 year olds should be eligible for
vaccination if they have down syndrome
severe neural disabilities or underlying
conditions that mean
their immune systems are suppressed in
addition
it advises vaccination for 12 to 15 year
olds with severe learning disabilities
with profound and multiple learning
disabilities or
who are on the learning disability
register and finally
vaccination is recommended for 12 to 17
year olds who are
household contacts of people with
suppressed immune systems and in that
latter case that is less about the
protection of the young person
and more about the protection of
somebody they may live with
now we'll shortly provide details of our
operational plans to vaccinate these
groups of young people
as quickly as possible and of course in
light of what i said earlier about
this advice being kept under review we
will make sure that we are prepared to
go
further as soon as that is recommended
if indeed that is
recommended now the final point of
vaccination i want to stress
is that if you are currently 17 years
old but if
you are due to turn 18 on or before the
31st of october this year
you are now eligible for vaccination as
part of this year's programme
you can self-register again through the
portal on nhs and form
or go to a drop-in centre so i want to
emphasize this point today
if you or indeed if you know somebody in
this category if you're due to turn 18
before the end of october
register for an appointment or go to a
drop-in center and get your
vaccination as soon as possible